Apple literally just made history
Apple's macsafe standard for wireless
charging their iPhones ever since the
iPhone 12 has now just been chosen as
the future wireless charging standard
for all devices globally yes globally
the wireless power Consortium just
announced that she too yes the
replacement for the original Chi is
literally built on Apple's Mac safe
technology using a new magnetic power
profile which is literally Max save and
it's going to be built in to the
standard for all devices yes that means
that Max safe is literally the future
I've been trying to tell you guys that
for the last couple of years ever since
it came out with the iPhone 12 I said
Mac safe is going to be huge it's going
to be a big deal it's going to be the
future it's going to be packed into the
Apple car all devices now the airpods
Pro 2 run on Mac sleep as well and now
Apple has won the entire industry with
their Max save connector yes the entire
industry is going to be on the standard
of G2 which the wireless power
Consortium says is going to directly
replace the original Qi certification
all together and this is an absolute
huge deal for the entire smartphone
industry and especially Apple because
apple is going to be making money
because this is the new standard and
they're going to be charging different
royalty fees and for people to use the
logo trademark everything with maxsafe
as G2 now I don't know if you know this
or not but currently with USBC you
actually have to pay a five thousand
dollar membership fee to join USB if and
that is annual so that you can continue
to use the USBC trademark and logo and
everything involved with that it's
actually not open source and completely
free vendors actually have to pay for it
now you do have the option of a one-time
six thousand dollar fee but then you
have to pay three thousand five hundred
dollars when you use their logo and to
avoid paying that fee you just pay the
annual five thousand dollars so imagine
now that the entire industry is
switching over to maxsafe and apple is
making money this is literally the
successor to Apple's lightning that's
bringing in a lot of royalties and
people are wondering how are they going
to ditch lightning if USBC is going to
be free they're not going to make money
well here you go there's maxafe becoming
chi2 and bringing in apple a ton of
royalty and Licensing Revenue now for
the last year or so I've been telling
you guys that maxsafe is my favorite
feature on the iPhone because it's
completely unique and it destroys all
other forms of wireless charging because
it's magnetic yes you have magnets built
in so you get perfect alignment all the
time you don't have issues with stuff
getting knocked out and moved out of the
way like for example in cars right now
they have a lot of wireless charging
pads built in and the issue is you take
a turn it slides off it's no longer
charging but now that maxsafe is
becoming the chi2 standard you're
literally gonna see new cars with
magsafe built into the dashes and the
center consoles so that you get perfect
wireless charging all the time and the
awesome thing about all of this is that
they're also showing off that you're
going to get better efficiency it's
going to be more green they're going to
have less landfill fill up because these
Max save connectors and chargers are
going to last a long time and it's going
to be standardized I'm so excited for
this because right now we even have
Android people Android fans that are
using magsafe stickers on the back of
their Android phones to use macsafe
accessories that's how good it is
there's even cases you can buy for
Android phones with macsafe magnets
built in and to see apple just
completely win over the industry and
become the new standard with Max save is
amazing like I thought Max 8 was going
to be the future but I didn't expect it
to be this big so imagine by the end of
the year according to the wireless power
Consortium we're gonna have G2 standard
Chargers on the market by the end of the
year available to everyone and my guess
is that within one or two years every
single smartphone including Android
smartphones will have magsafe batteries
built into the back of those smartphones
and apple is getting their cut this is
the best thing that could ever happen to
Apple I can't believe they pulled it off
now getting even deeper if you think
about Apple's issues right now in the EU
with them forcing them to ditch my
lightning in adopt the USBC standard to
have a standardized charging connector
well what if
Apple's Max safe will now qualify or
pass as that standard because now it's
literally standardized across the
industry so Apple can say well hey we
have a standard max save charger on the
back we no longer need USBC I don't know
I'm not sure if it's limited to USBC or
if it's just any kind of wireless
charging standard but if that's the case
and apple was able to surpass and go
around all those laws by making their
own Max safe charger the standard for
the entire industry globally that would
be absolutely insane now macsafe is the
future I believe because even if the
next iPhone 15 lineup later this year
gets USBC we're gonna get three years of
USBC iPhones and then I believe that in
2026 apple is going to have completely
portless iPhones relying on macsafe and
I do believe that it's going to get a
lot faster and a lot more efficient so
that's going to be really really big for
apple and there's a chance that if all
the other smartphones Android phones
support maxsafe they could also
eventually go portless as well that just
blows my mind that the entire industry
is going to be following in Apple's
footsteps now in terms of Apple making
money off of royalties I came across
this very interesting post about five
years ago from hrh George J Ricky saying
that what Apple wants badly is to get a
royalty fee from every computer phone
and device produced even 10 percent that
failed with firewire the usbif only
makes Open Standards so they would not
agree to anything Apple required Apple
could however push for a technology they
have patented to be optional then they
could convince device manufacturers
their Edition was such a great thing and
then computer manufacturers would
include it in order to enable those
devices then they can charge their 10
cents 10 cents on billions of devices
for doing nothing is a lot of money
there are lots of bits of intellectual
property via patents and copyrights and
a modern computer and lots of companies
earning fractions of pennies so imagine
Apple earning royalties even 10 cents on
every single mag safe design with Max
save charging that is insane amounts of
money for Apple that is a huge success
and even if Apple can't make any
royalties or even limited royalties on
this whole Max save thing imagine the
entire Market of Mac safe accessories
just entirely blowing up and becoming
hugely popular because every single
smartphone is gonna have Max save G2
built in now if you have any other
thoughts you want to share let me know
down in the comments section below and
if you want to pick up one of those
macsafe Chargers in advance you can find
it using the YouTube product tagging
feature thanks for watching click that
Circle button to subscribe for more
videos like this one and we'll see you
in the next video
[Music]